we begin with breaking news out of gaza
where the israeli military has launched
strikes against several targets the
operation follows days of tension after
the arrest of a senior palestinian
leader of the group islamic jihad
joins us live now from gaza i believe
she's on the phone yuma what more can
you tell us about this attack
yes emily so uh basically uh the israeli
strikes on the gaza strip in different
locations just started suddenly uh
really we know that we're in the middle
of yes tensions and threats and warning
messages between the
palestinian side and the israeli site
but we also know that there are strong
radiations going on and suddenly uh
israeli strikes take place uh in
actually different locations at the same
time there was a targeting in a
palestine tower in one of the
residential uh it's a residential
building in one of the residential
apartments in that tower uh it was
targeted with a missile and at the same
time there was a targeting in the
northern part of the strip and in the
southern part of the strip
until now we know that two people have
uh died and other numbers have been
injured they have all arrived to shifa
and
brigades said that their northern
commander uh
[Music]
is the person who has been assassinated
in that apartment targeting
yumna
we mentioned that this comes after the
arrest of a senior palestinian can you
give us a context into what led up to
this attack
true uh
last week the
society who is also a leader in islamic
jihad was arrested in jain after the
israeli forces invaded the junior
refugee camp and arrested basham assadi
he was
injured as they said in the we've seen
pictures of him uh islamic jihad since
that time has been uh asking for a day
uh immediate to release of the standard
society
but there was no response from the
israeli site until we know that the
israeli court said that they have
extended his detention for another eight
days to complete his interrogation uh
then islamic had put two conditions for
the threats and warnings as they said
they are in high alert and ready for any
escalation in case uh any danger is uh
subjected to the life of the saudi and
also
who is another islamic jihad a prisoner
who is detained uh under administrative
uh detention he has been on hunger
strike for uh over
146 days now and his condition is
severely
dangerous islamic jihad has put these
two conditions as the conditions for uh
the quietness and columnists to return
between the gaza fighting groups and
israel
we've seen the
quickly the development developing of
the events where the israeli
side
forced a closure on the israeli cities
in the southern uh that are adjacent to
the gospel strip uh there is a curfew
there uh people are not allowed to come
in or out the borders of the gospel
strip kerem abu salim uh and uh aries
checkpoints have been completely closed
for four days now in a row not allowing
people like allowing goods or any
materials to enter the golden strip as
mediations were taking place through
these days to not escalate
the conditions further uh so that we do
not
find ourselves in another round of
escalation between uh the israeli forces
and the palestinian fighting group until
these strikes have suddenly erupted
we've been looking at some pictures of
people uh on the ground there clearly
angry and distressed what's the mood
like what has the moon been like over
the last
couple of days and what's it like at the
moment in gaza
in the past couple of days as we have
been uh witnessing uh uh the closure of
the crossings and uh knowing that the
power the soul power plant in gaza might
actually shut down if fuel is not
entered in in the coming uh hours or the
coming days
we were very surprised that today they
allowed truck
fuel about four tracks of fuel to enter
uh in in in uh uh to enter through the
academic crossing just for the power
plant to stay running and that was uh
considered a very uh optimistic move we
thought that this is the beginning of a
calmness the people here in gaza now
know that uh the beginning of such race
and assassination the strategy of
assassination that israel implements
with leaders of the palestinian fighting
groups
very much is a dangerous
strategy that may actually cause a wider
complicated escalation it might even
take days now no doubt we'll cross back
to you as things develop that was yumna
al-sayed on the phone there for us live
from gaza